[Music]
well john
i don't get to say this very often
at home
and occasionally i get to say it here
i was right
i was right we are in a recession but
barely
it's such a wimpy little recession it
doesn't even count it looks to me like a
rounding error it really is ridiculous i
mean so the a recession if you don't
know we've been laughing about this last
couple days because the white house you
know anytime somebody doesn't like a
term these days they just redefine it so
we made fun of you redefining anxiety
and and biden white house came out and
tried to redefine what a recession is
and
you can't it's it's econ 101. they teach
you in your first week in class in
college i mean come on a recession is
two consecutive quarters of the gross
domestic product
which is the adding up of all the goods
and services produced in the united
states shrinking
it's a little bit less
two quarters in a row it receded like my
hairline yes okay that's what a
recession is it receded however this one
didn't recede nearly as far as my
hairline
i could say this recession is such a
joke
that it's not even a real recession it's
not even a good one i mean as it went
down like one and something one and a
quarter one and a half percent first
quarter
last quarter we got the numbers out just
a few hours ago
they it went down 0.9
percent that's like a rounding error
this is like getting a ticket for going
71 in in a 70. it's like come on man i
was speeding 70 and a half that's right
i was speeding but come on man
70.9 in the 70. oh this is ridiculous so
now the the uh democrats are all gonna
run around in circles acting like it's
no big deal because it's really no big
deal uh and uh the republicans are all
gonna scream at the top of their lungs
we're dying it's in a recession biden
has crashed the economy oh my god and no
no neither one is true by the way we are
in a recession and the economy is not
good
but it is this is not like a hurricane
recession this is a
a light mist it's not like the last one
we experienced it's not even a real
rainstorm in q2
when
it hit
in 2020 right yeah we shut down the
world
and the economy completely shrunk by
like what uh 25 or 30 percent has shrunk
yes during quarantine right because
everybody's sitting at home eating
donuts right donuts went up plexiglas
went up but everything else went down
right and so then they came out of their
caves and bought everything in sight and
the economy exploded by 35 the next
quarter so that was a bizarre thing in
2020 but what we are is we we are
experiencing a slower economy it's not
growing it's not a time of prosperity
for sure
but it is not chicken little you don't
have to get your helmet out it's just
0.9
i was telling rachel that it could have
been up like 0.2 i i mean the numbers we
were getting there's a lot of precursor
reports that come out that you can read
and so i was seeing the indicators i
knew it was going to be basically flat
but it could have been up 0.25 it could
have been up a quarter of a percent and
then we wouldn't technically been in a
recession which would be like
what 30.35
difference in where we are right and it
would have been reversed the the the
the right would have been saying
well i mean it's really a recession and
the left was saying see look at how
wonderful we bailed it out right
and neither one is true okay it's not
the end of the world don't let the right
tell you that because they're trying to
win the midterms uh based on the
recession it they need to win it based
on something else because there's not
much of the left this is a wimpy little
misty math isn't real again tiny
recession okay so
so in all reality but but it does suck
because we're not booming okay so yeah
it's obviously when the economy is not
on fire all in all reality it's hurting
i'm just a guy with two little kids and
stuff's expensive stuff
that's inflation what do i do that's
inflation right this means nothing
well that's helpful like just the
regular other than the economy is not
it's kind of
you know it's just it's going for a walk
it's not going for a run
gotcha you know and it's and it's a slow
walk
but it's not had a heart attack in an
icu either okay so there you go
stretch this metaphor all we can but but
you said something important for the
average guy like me this number means
nothing means nothing other than the
idea of the economy slow so turn the
news off the economy's slow yes okay but
it's not a deep dark i mean i'm 62 years
old i've seen some dark recessions
they're not fun right that's a whole
bunch of layoffs a bunch of businesses
aren't doing business so they don't need
people they're not buying stuff because
they're not doing business so they're
goods that they produce they're not
producing them because they're not doing
business and so it slows down it's not
good it's ugly recessions are ugly uh
but this one's a joke
this one's just moderately unpleasant
but the uh uh
this one could get a date i mean it's
not really ugly right so
hey yes
this is a recession like me and you and
we both ended up getting married this is
good
this is good i could get a date
but i do get to tell rachel cruz i was
right
hey this is worth something because she
was dogging me on the air the other day
because i said it might be up a quarter
of a percent she said wait a minute
america he just said he might be wrong
it's like yeah rachel calm down
yeah i could have been wrong but i
actually wasn't so i'm really kind of
basking in this a little bit because i
did call it a while back i thought we
were going into recession and we did but
you said what it's such a joke it's
gonna be a minor i could've missed it as
easy as i hit it truthfully because it's
basically flatline it's just
right down the middle so that that's the
thing so you're gonna hear this all over
the news and you're gonna hear the fed
increase the interest rates again
yesterday to slow inflation which is
stupid on steroids they're screwing
around with the economy they need to
leave it alone let it heal itself it's
going to be all right but they're going
to mess this thing up
and uh just man when you start messing
with supply demand stuff and you start
messing and tinkering with pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
yeah we can't complete a sentence it's
not a good thing okay so let me ask you
this let's let's take this metaphor
because that's my bigger concern
you have a couple and their marriage
it's fine things are fine and you're
going for a walk and you've got the one
person who's saying
hey we should probably talk last night
um you i just felt
and the other person's saying
i was in a bad mood
and we're going to dig into this and
well what if we just we're going to
we're going to try to start well let's
start doing this together let's do this
and we need to go do this we should
probably go sign up for this and let's
read this book to get another person
saying hey is he tired
there comes a point when the
intervention becomes worse than anything
that was actually going on is there a
moment here so that's a long long
drawn-out analogy here to say got lost
in your analogy okay now not caught up i
got it okay is in other words you know
you're making a mountain out of my wheel
can you can we tinker with this and the
tinker's gonna crash the car well it's
not gonna crash it but it could make it
worse instead of making it better
um you know it's just
there's first rule is do no harm right
and so
exactly kick your hands off if you don't
know what's going on take your hands off
for a second the beautiful thing about
capitalism is it has a real tendency to
heal itself if you leave it alone okay
like crooks they don't make it because
people quit doing business with them why
because they're crooks
yeah then eventually if your product is
brakes on you
if you if you if you if you make a
crappy car
eventually people call it a pinto i mean
you know i mean you know that that's
eventually the marketplace will punish
you for being stupid and it will cleanse
itself but then it does that with cycles
as well but god i'm mighty we have to
mess with it